[Música]
Hola Yo soy Natalia Cabrera parada y
esto es aquí América del magazine de
France 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias y las historias de nuestro
continente y esto es lo que veremos hoy
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden recibió en la oficina ovala su
homólogo colombiano Gustavo Petro 8
meses después de que este último llegara
a la casa de nariño la llamada guerra
contra las drogas la democracia en
Venezuela y una economía sin
combustibles fósiles estuvieron en el
centro de las conversaciones
América Latina que había tratado de
mantenerse al margen de la Guerra de
Ucrania empieza a tomar posiciones y las
partes buscan apoyo mientras el
canciller ruso sergei lavrov emprendió
una gira que lo llevó a Brasil Venezuela
en Nicaragua y Cuba el presidente
ucraniano bolodinewski habló esta semana
ante el congreso mexicano
y explotó en el aire el cohete starship
de la compañía spacex del Magnate y elon
musk esto minutos después de haber
despegado con éxito desde Texas el
cohete constituía una primera prueba
para desarrollar tecnología para llevar
a los humanos al espacio
y vamos de inmediato a Estados Unidos
desde donde llega la imagen de la semana
el primer presidente de izquierda de
Colombia Gustavo Petro llegó a la casa
blanca para una reunión con el
mandatario estadounidense Joe biden en
medio de risas que llegaron por la
felicitación de biden a Petro por su
cumpleaños el 19 de abril los
mandatarios discutieron temas serios
como un eventual cambio de enfoque en la
llamada lucha contra las drogas el
tránsito hacia las energías limpias la
democracia en Venezuela y la migración
hacia el norte para la cual Colombia es
un importante punto de tránsito de
quienes buscan el llamado sueño
americano
ambos reiteraron que se puede hacer más
para profundizarlos ya estrechos
vínculos entre las dos naciones y para
trabajar por estos objetivos sobre la
guerra contra las drogas un tema
delicado en la Unión Americana vaiden
evitó hablar de un cambio de estrategia
y reiteró la importancia de la lucha
contra el narcotráfico varias naciones
sudamericanas han pedido que se cambie
el enfoque para controlar el consumo en
territorio estadounidense escuchemos a
biden estamos trabajando para
contrarrestar el tráfico de narcóticos y
atender los niveles históricos de
migración en nuestro hemisferio
especialmente a través del tapón del
Darién otro tema central de la agenda
fue la crisis en Venezuela Petro pidió a
Washington levantar las sanciones en
contra del régimen de Nicolás maduro
para destacar el diálogo con la
oposición de Cara a la reunión que tiene
lugar el 25 de abril en Bogotá en la que
participarán representantes tanto del
oficialismo como de la oposición y
delegaciones de Francia Alemania
Argentina Ecuador Brasil y Canadá baiden
condicion ó esto a que primero se
celebren elecciones escuchemos al
presidente colombiano hablar al respecto
no se condicionó digamos quedó planteado
sobre la mesa
una estrategia que
es hacer primero elecciones y después
levantar sanciones o
paulatinamente en la medida en que se va
cumpliendo una agenda una agenda
electoral se vaya también paralelamente
levantando progresivamente sanciones No
yo no soy mediador si vienen los temas
anteriores no se vislumbran conclusiones
claras una de las prioridades de Petro
en la reunión con vaina era abordar
políticas para combatir el cambio
climático frente a esto logró que el
mandatario estadounidense pidiera al
congreso a probar un desembolso de 500
millones de dólares para proteger la
amazonía
y vamos a quedarnos allí en Washington
pero cambiamos de tema según el más
reciente censo hay aproximadamente 62
millones y medio de hispanos es decir
casi el 20% de la población total del
país sin embargo solo el 10% de los
congresistas son latinos el corresponsal
de France 24 en Washington Cristóbal
Vázquez habló con algunos de ellos y nos
explica Por qué es tan baja la
representación hispana en el congreso
nuevos congresistas hispanos fueron
electos en las pasadas elecciones
legislativas para la representante a la
cámara por Nuevo México Teresa Fernández
existe un problema de baja
representatividad hispana que se origina
en el diseño de los distritos
electorales en el país lo que en Estados
Unidos electoral
sabemos que hacen lo que se conoce como
empaquetamiento y división de los
distritos electorales es decir ponen a
todos los latinos en un mismo Distrito
electoral y solo representamos ese
Distrito cuando podríamos tener los
votos para representar dos o tres
distritos más también nos dividen muchos
distritos y nos quitan el poder político
y esto está pasando en todo el país
de los 47 latinos que hacen parte de la
cámara de representantes 35 son
demócratas y doce republicanos Mario
Díaz valarte republicano por la Florida
dice que es clave para la democracia
aumentar el número de latinos en el
congreso
en toda la negociaciones en todos los
temas Ahora hay latinos hispanos que
representan a las comunidades diversas a
través de esta nación Y eso solamente
ayuda no solamente al proceso este
proceso legislativo pero yo creo que
ayuda a esta nación
los hispanos son La minoría más grande
en Estados Unidos
vicepresidente de campañas y alianzas
para la organización voto latino dice
que este es el grupo poblacional que más
crece en el país y de ahí la importancia
de fomentar y financiar su participación
en la política
sabemos que cada 30 segundos un latino
cumple 18 años entre los años 2020 Y
2024 en este ciclo presidencial veremos
4 millones de nuevos votantes latinos
eso es poder la creciente discriminación
contra los hispanos y las teorías de
Conspiración como la del Gran reemplazo
y argumenta que los migrantes van a
quitarle el poder político y económico a
la población Blanca son obstáculos para
balancear la representatividad hispana
en el congreso y en la política de
Estados Unidos
y América Latina había evitado durante
más de un año tomar partido sobre la
guerra en Ucrania dicha política parece
haber dado un giro esta semana con
algunas naciones posicionándose a favor
de Rusia al recibir al canciller sergei
laprop el jefe de la diplomacia rusa
realizó una gira que lo llevó a Brasil
donde lo recibió el ministro de asuntos
exteriores ya que el presidente Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva se encontraba de
gira por emiratos árabes Unidos y China
además fue recibido por Daniel Ortega en
Nicaragua en Venezuela por Nicolás
maduro y por último por Miguel Díaz
canel en Cuba
[Música]
agradecemos mucho el hecho de que desde
el inicio mismo de la operación militar
especial nuestros amigos cubanos el
presidente Díaz canel y otros
representantes de la dirección
delinearon muy claramente su posición y
expresaron plena comprensión en sus
evaluaciones de las razones que llevaron
a la situación actual me refiero a la
imprudente expansión de la otan
directamente a nuestras fronteras
y Lula de Esta visita de emiratos árabes
Unidos y a China acusó a Estados Unidos
y a los países de la Unión Europea de
querer prolongar la guerra en Ucrania el
portavoz de relaciones exteriores del
bloque de los 27 lo negó y la Casa
Blanca dijo que los comentarios eran
Sencillamente falsos
Estados Unidos Tiene que dejar de
fomentar la guerra y empezar a hablar de
paz la Unión Europea tiene que empezar a
hablar de paz para que podamos convencer
a putinyanski de que la paz interesa
todo el mundo
no es verdad que la Unión Europea y
Estados Unidos alargan el conflicto
Ucrania es víctima de una agresión que
viola la carta de Naciones Unidas y
estamos ayudando a Ucrania a defenderse
porque si no afrontaría su destrucción
por su parte el presidente de Ucrania
voló y mirza lens y dio un discurso ante
la cámara de diputados de México a
través de una videollamada durante 13
minutos
intentó hacer un llamado a los
congresistas mexicanos para que
respalden a kiev en la guerra el
mandatario mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador ha sido reacio a apoyar a
Ucrania bajo el argumento de la no
intervención selensky recordó que en
febrero pidió una cumbre de los países
latinoamericanos para lo que considero
clave un llamado de México a las demás
naciones de la región
Ucrania ya propuso a la comunidad de
América Latina a organizar una Cumbre
especial y Mostrar y posición de
principio globales importantes de la
integridad territorial la paz y respeto
entre los pueblos la soberanía de las
Naciones creo que con la ayuda de México
eso podría ser mucho más rápido su voto
en la asamblea general de la ONU y en
otros organismos internacionales es muy
importante es el voto para defender los
principios y objetivos de la carta de la
ONU y Por ende para defender la
integridad territorial de Ucrania y de
todas las naciones del mundo y sigamos
en Cuba como se esperaba Miguel Díaz
canel fue nombrado presidente de La Isla
durante la legislatura del parlamento en
la sesión de esta semana se eligió
además al vicepresidente al Primer
Ministro y a los demás miembros del
gabinete Rafael Pérez nos trae más
detalles del proceso parlamentario
no hubo sorpresas pero casi unanimidad
con más del 97% de los votos Miguel Díaz
canel accedió a un segundo mandato en
Cuba
declaro electroditado Miguel Díaz
Bermúdez presidente de la república de
Cuba serán otros cinco años con el
timonel de los destinos de la isla y un
último periodo según la constitución en
lo que pueda representar el último acto
de formación de gobierno en presencia de
los fundadores políticos del país Díaz
canel tuvo palabras para los que lo
adversan Pero no puedo dejar de
contrastar actitudes la de los que
critican del modo más efectivo luchando
haciendo mostrando o creando soluciones
y la de aquellos que solo ven los
errores y las culpas de otros a su vez
el jefe de estado propuso a Manuel
marrero para desempeñarse como Primer
Ministro mandato ratificado por la
asamblea la máxima dirección del país se
mantiene intacta solo el consejo de
ministros sufrió leves cambios seis
nuevos integrantes fueron propuestos de
la generación de guerrilleros de Fidel
solo uno se mantiene Ramiro Valdez
Menéndez próximo a cumplir 91 años quien
se desempeña como viceprimer ministro
varios son los retos que enfrenta el
mandatario para sus próximos cinco años
entre ellos tomar un rumbo propio y las
renovaciones que ello implica con la
inercia de este primer mandato en que lo
que primo es somos continuidad y la
rigidez ideológica frente al pragmatismo
económico o si introducirá los cambios
que todo el mundo Espera que se produzca
Cuba viene golpeada por las
consecuencias de la pandemia un
endurecimiento de las sanciones de
Estados Unidos en las que Joe no ha dado
marcha atrás y dificultades internas
como escasez de combustible y un aumento
en el costo de vida que ha generado
protestas inéditas retos para los que el
quinto presidente de Cuba desde 1959
tendrá una segunda oportunidad para
encontrar soluciones
en Brasil dimitió el jefe de la
seguridad institucional de la
presidencia marco Edson González Díaz un
militar en la reserva de plena confianza
del presidente Lula lo hizo luego de que
medios de comunicación publicaran
imágenes en las que se le ve junto a los
manifestantes que asaltaron el ocho de
enero las sedes de los tres poderes en
Brasilia
gonzálvez asegura que estaba ayudando a
evacuar a la gente y que incluso sacó a
tres personas del despacho del propio
Lula para la oposición es una muestra de
que el gobierno dejó de hacer cosas ese
día para generar una ola de apoyo al
presidente una acusación que el gobierno
tacha de Absurda y ofrece su
colaboración en las investigaciones
y me despido con imágenes del
lanzamiento del cohete starship de
spacex
[Música]
el cohete despegó desde Boca Chica en
Texas pero explotó segundos después el
dueño de la compañía elon musk calificó
de todas maneras como un éxito la
operación que constituía en los primeros
pasos para llevar Humanos a la luna a
Marte y más allá en nuestro sistema
solar gracias por acompañarme en esta
emisión de aquí América por favor
envíenme sus comentarios en redes
sociales a la dirección que ven en su
pantalla en la producción estuvo
Giovanni agudelo pueden ver esta emisión
en las anteriores en nuestra página web
France 24.com y Para más información de
nuestro continente Sigan viendo France
[Música]
la historia de nuestro